you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour une petite compilation de
jeux cool cette fois puisque des fois
ils sont un peu folle où on commence
tout de suite avec un jeu s'appelle snif
drôle de blague
alors on est donc sur ce niveau là où
c'est un jeu on commence dans une
chambre de d'asile psychiatrique si vous
voulez et en fait on doit se servir de
médicaments ou de drogues je crois pour
s'évader a par exemple la y en a hop je
l'apprends jeu là je la sniffe et je
peux passer a trait à l'apport voilà
c'est bien c'est bizarre du coup on se
trouve en dehors de notre monnaie dans
l'illégalité la plus totale [ __ ]
voyage ça va y avoir un gain est vas-y
oui oui ça me mettrait mal plus tard il
n'est pas habitué lui et boit du lait en
soirée tout à space to joy ou oui mais
c'est de monter ça c'est non non non
c'est bien trop [ __ ] alors on a une
perf ici ouais ben c'est ce qui est bien
c'est que c'est pas de look du tout ce
jeu ça fait vraiment plaisir
il ya plein de poils partout j'en ai
marre je sais pas c'est pas les verts
vient pas comme dans game of thrones et
l'été arrive et du coup les poils de
chat avec bordel l'abaya de la drogue
alors regardez moi ce petit heures tout
en optant culé arrive à défoncer
d'accord il est plutôt rapide en fait un
bonne qu'il base et bien non ok ok j'ai
la tête à l'envers
mais toi aussi tourné dans la drôme
battra voteront dans le vide quoi indila
non mais il a pas d'humour se gardera
ses deux gtx par laser je pense que du
coup j'ai besoin du deuxième truc de
drogue et là bas pour neutraliser le
deuxième garde et où est mon gars humana
dans le ciboulot
comme disait gillet zezel hop la halle
était drogué ou bétail à des lasers à
l'aller on se souvient des cours d'athlé
là j'ai en fait pour battre les [ __ ]
c'est pas grave on imagine n'ont quà
héééé et on fait du lobby et n ont en
fait ils veulent tous dansé logobi ici
on va attendre qu'il revienne voilà on
fait comme la corde à sauter et [ __ ]
pardon on prend le truc on est beau la
juste mais non mais c'est trop mal fait
ma part ag / s'attendait l'ont fait que
de rage et en ce moment faut se détendre
un peu là et je peux pas sauter sur le
tueur bord voilà voilà du coup j'ai ma
drogue la gauche bah oui bon
non pas dans le film va se passer en
fait ça il faut pas lui mettre la
pression à will keep your fucking ass
mat faux kg transforme en moi ça
commence à se pressent alors y'a quoi
ici à part notre garde non c'est la
porte pour s'évader de l'hôpital
il faut un truc de drogue pour casser la
porte c'est maintenant ou jamais
l'épreuve ultime suis tendu et auto shop
tirs on a la joie la joie s'empare de
nous et et et mais non mais c'est
sérieux mais c'était pas la bonne trempe
que je rangement bats les couilles je
m'en bats les coûts totaux à eux c'est
pas et jean-michel je m'en bats les
steaks est vraiment un homme
ta mère ta bonne grosse merde on est où
là mais du coup ça ok s'activent paint
est ici quand même donc on est bien on
attend avec sa part carrément couilles
kouame par abscon à fait d'accord la
santé a donc là on a on a une drogue
c'est pour aller de l'autre côté de la
porte qu'elle en est d'accord sillage
aller ok enfin parfois plus tôt vous
avez compris ok battle engagé thomas
tamayo trop fort pour moi mais j'ai pas
trop comment voulez vous que les
coutumes attrapera jamais jean-michel
esquive la drogue peut péter la messe en
plein jeu vous met tous à la mode au la
drogue drogue
elle s'est beaucoup trop dur web on est
tous au mal et ce dès qu'on attend le
mec qui sait tout faire avec et risque
la drogue a droit à temps mais c'est
super dur c'est abusé la série connaît
non mais regardez on est trop con
regarder aux flammes et oui monsieur lui
est mort attendent ou toucher t4 et je
rêvais pas d'ailleurs c'est moi qui lui
faisait des prises de catch à la temps
là il ya un mec là ouais merci counter
strike up et on passe de l'autre côté
ok on continue [ __ ] par contre j'ai pu
drogue une folle à breuil là où il ya
trois lasers et 90% de chances de mourir
c'est la bonne direction en est que non
mais t'es sérieux
attendez de la terre qui tourne autour
des poteaux arrêté un moment
ohlala oh là là là là où est la porte de
sortie s'il vous plaît excusez moi où il
a sorti parce que je sais que même ces
mecs sont promus rien est lui totalement
beau mais il est rentré ici en 2006 puis
voilà depuis les light blues rendait la
drogue aux abonnés on va prendre ça et
on va tracer ok vous êtes prêts
ah ah ah non non la russe n'a aucun
conflit
je déteste [ __ ] ou et la sorte il a
regardé c'est là c'est là ça c'est le
couloir final ce final corridor on
l'appelle dans le milieu tu décède
voilà à nom vient d'affronter dans les
lasers de retour dans le final comme i
do we can find the slugz je le tente en
tente en cours est faite aux tétouan
tais toi tais toi ce pas lui maintenant
ok ok ok oh non pas au quai aux officier
d'une telle ou telle ou telle bombe
algérien après j'ai rien compris mais
c'est à dire je suis là il tente de nous
lobotomiser reproduisait attentivement
ce que je vais faire
qu'est ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui on
est maintenant sur super je vous ai dis
qu'aujourd'hui en tester des jeux style
et c'est l'autre cas click to start le
principe est génial en gros qu'on est à
l'arrêt le temps est au ralenti en
bullet time
et quand on marche le temps passe
normalement voilà nul oh là là c'était
mon style
swap la super top super hot aux diamants
qu'ils essaient de créer une sorte de
secte rôle au tt tt tegra ayache voir
quand même la mère cachée quelque part
non regarde moi ce petit [ __ ] hockey
ou mais qui ça tellement compliqué il y
en a partout bordel au il est arrivé il
a sauvé son pote mais c'est tellement
style et [ __ ] je suis en érection de
stella aulas assure la merde je suppute
et là je dépends d'un coup je sais me
mall faut que je prenne le gun ok ok ok
ah non en fait tout est bon si je crois
je dirais que mon ban estelle à schengen
et de tout en haut mer j'ai pu de balle
le regarder comment cette idée commence
à affoler tout s'est tellement situe là
les enfants je pourrais jouer à ça toute
ma vie toute la journée
annick et un look et aux plats à non il
est décédé
il aurait 5 oh [ __ ] j'ai fait la balle
m'a vraiment fait une cicatrice quoi
harry potter c'est comme ça que la
biennale qui arrive elle a fait ça est
si je meurs soldes année je vais craquer
mon slip
[Musique]
oh lola lola super hot swap la secte ça
suffit la boss fights
c'est quoi c'est un grand mec ou c'est
juste un million de petits mecs bah
ouais elle bossait nu quoi c est tout le
monde a toutes les armes lui la plus
d'armes du coudon qu'il est nulle part
mais il prend sa douche quand arrive un
jour il m'a dit m'a juste à travers la
fenêtre
ok et cesser la fin non c'est là c'est
la fin du jeu à temps mais c'est juste
le jeu indé le pistil auxquelles ont
déjoué quoi douter tout est parfait et
ça demande du ce qu'il sait style et ses
styles et c'est stylé ces styles et on
est maintenant sur choupi mart et plus
stylée que les deux jeux convient de
faire réunissent passe par mensonge mémo
bienvenue à votre premier jour en tant
que caissier a chopé martin allez c'est
parti le reste on s'en fout alors du
coup oui au jour je pas cette pub c ou
pourra entrer le code du fruit c'est une
pièce 0,17
ok c'est bon 40 78 attention à vous dire
quoi
allez tiens je pèse mes ou c ou c ou que
je je je paye là je l'habille l'âge la
roche dans ma poche en bas ok il est à
tous les partis sans payer
vigile [ __ ] ou là il est fâcheux sans
grincheux je demande s'il n 4 il lui
trouve un patient le mec quoi calme-toi
abuser un gros porc qu ils achètent une
pomme et de packs de bière la pomme
c'est juste pour se réconforter
moralement c'est ça ton petit sac
ma vie est cool es tu soupire pas dans
mon magasin allez hop j'encaisse tiens
tiens voilà et puis il ya une annonce et
la clope card faut pas qu'il oublie ça
bug bas et oublié sa carte ça bug au but
mais fait chier quoi taper c'est dur
d'être testé depuis sanaa et la gentille
afin de cette petite compilation de
trois jeux gratuits geste vous a plu
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude je suis content puisque
les deux premiers jeux qu'on a testé
était quand même excellent labour ce
dernier en qualité et à un peu à peu au
dessus je trouve moi je me trompe et de
beaux concertos seront bientôt dans une
nouvelle vidéo merci d'avoir gardé tu as
tout le monde portez vous bien pis
[Musique]